vor drei jahren ist johnson ige aus
nigeria geflüchtet wegen seiner
politischen anschauen sagt er wurde es
gefährlich für ihn er hat asyl in
deutschland beantragt so lange das nicht
bewilligt ist droht ihm die abschiebung
eine harte belassen
doch glücklicherweise gebe es fußball
zum training kommen und gemeinsam
spielen und reden können ist das wie
eine befreiung
solange wir spielen könnt ihr all die
probleme die wir sonst haben für eine
zeit lang vergessen beim sv babelsberg
in potsdam
bekommen die flüchtlinge nicht nur die
möglichkeit zu spielen
sie haben sogar eine eigene mannschaft
gegründet
wer kam united 0 3 unterstützung bekommt
das multinationale team nicht nur vom
verein sondern auch von den babelsberger
fans die haben zum beispiel die trikots
finanziert wurde immer schon mit
flüchtlingen auch gekocht oder zusammen
gegessen und es wurde immer was
unternommen
es ist schon seit vielen jahren
normalität hier bei uns in babelsberg
und im prinzip war die gründung der
mannschaft dann nur ein logischer
schritt in der kommenden saison will
wellcome united um punkte spielen wie
alle neulinge zunächst ganz unten in der
kreisklasse
und hier beginnt das problem denn dafür
braucht jeder fußballer einen
spielerpass so schreibt es der
internationale fußballverband fifa vor
und der deutsche fußball-bund der dfb
muss das umsetzen
im fall der flüchtlinge von wellcome
united muss der dfb nun zuerst in deren
heimatländern wie nigeria oder
tschetschenien nachfragen ob sie dort
bei einem verein gemeldet sind
es ist einfach eine prozedur von 23
monaten
und oft verstehen die spieler selbst
einfach nicht warum das so lange dauert
weil dann kommt ein deutscher oder eu
bürger in die mannschaft und er kann ihn
plötzlich zwei wochen später schön
spielen
die sozialarbeiterin caroline gaffron
hat schon mehrmals fußballspieler die
nach deutschland geflüchtet sind an
einen verein weiter vermittelt und jedes
mal war es ein bürokratischer
hindernislauf bis zu einer bestimmten
liga kann man ja auch sagen okay wir
verzichten auf diesen auf diese anfrage
weil somalia afghanistan syrien die wir
haben bestimmt auch bessere sachen zu
tun als auf spielerpass anfragen zu
reagieren beziehungsweise gibt es
wahrscheinlich die behörden gar nicht
mehr zuständig für wellcome united 0 3
ist der fußball landesverband
brandenburg
hier rollt man zwar ein dass die
heimatländer der flüchtlinge auf
anfragen eigentlich nie reagieren
grundsätzlich aber verteidigt man die
strikten regeln der fifa es kann ja auch
sein dass ein spieler unter falschen
voraussetzungen beantragt wird dass ein
vertrag existiert oder eine starre
besteht und diese dinge müssen natürlich
geprüft werden und daher hat die fifa
hat diese 30 tage frist festgelegt in
der die verbände reagieren können viele
asylbewerber die fußball als
freizeitsport betragen haben aber
faktisch wesentlich länger gewartet
sie fühlen sich gegängelt durch so viele
deutsche gründlichkeit in seiner werbung
schreibt der dfb das thema integration
ganz groß in diesem spot die eltern der
kicker aus der deutschen nationalelf
weltmeister weil hier viele kulturen
erfolgreich zusammen spielen
kinder spielen in der deutschen fußball
nationalmannschaft dfb dass integration
viel integration
die fans des sv babelsberg sehen das
skeptisch sie finden
der dfb könne durchaus mehr tun da ja
auch der gesellschaftspolitische
anspruch den der dfb auch nach außen den
dreck manchmal dabei handelnden personen
vielleicht doch noch gar nicht so
verankert ist wie es wünschenswert wäre
sondern dass es immer druck von außen
bedarf dass der dfb probleme erkennt und
dann dementsprechend handelt anstatt
selbst schon mal vielleicht initiativen
zu unterstützen oder sich ideen
auszudenken um dann wirklich dieses mass
integration auch zu leben nach außen und
das auch komplett durch zu leben
der brandenburger fußballverband
jedenfalls verspricht jetzt keiner der
kicker von wellcome united muss lange
auf seinen spielerpass warten in der
kommenden saison wollen sie dann so
richtig um punkte spielen
zumindest die die bis dahin nicht
abgeschoben worden sind